in the gloucestershire countryside The
Vines are budding but deep in three
choirs Vineyard there is science
underway a new method of controlling
weeds is being tested no herbicides
being sprayed or Roots dug up in instead
it uses electricity each of these flaps
contain electrodes and as electricity
passes through them it completes a
circuit and the heat generated
essentially frazzles any weeds that they
come into contact with
the device root wave has been designed
in conjunction with Coventry University
the system could mean an end to
herbicides that could be damaging to the
environment and potentially our health
chemicals are going up in price all the
time where we will be 10 or 15 years
from now I can't begin to imagine we've
used glyphosate weed killer for 30 years
here and I think it's time that we we
found opportunities to where to change
from that and move on the use of
herbicides and pesticides in the UK is
in the spotlight especially since brexit
and bans imposed in EU countries the
challenge is finding an alternative to
chemicals that work on the same scale
for Farmers we have better weed control
in fewer treatments so for an
operational point of view it's actually
easier to to manage as a farmer in
addition we don't have the issues such
as a high wind that you do with
herbicide so the farmer has more Choice
when and where to weed
the soil Association says previous
Trials of electric weed killing showed
no damage to soil biology with this
product available from the summer
blasting weeds with electric rather than
chemicals could be the latest climate
friendly alternative Dan Whitehead Sky
News in gloucestershire